foreign
did you know that targeted advertising
is an intrusive practice that monitors
your online activities regarding your
preferences dislikes and personal
information puts your data at risk most
people tune out as soon as the
commercial begins making it ineffective
well the basic attention token or bat is
a revolutionary advertising method that
addresses flaws in traditional
advertising using the blockchain bat
creates a more efficient and transparent
process for purchasing and selling
advertising space but how exactly well
to answer all your questions related to
basic attention token simply learn has
created a new video on what is basic
attention token so let me take you
through it but before that if you like
watching videos on interesting topics
like this then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
now let me first take you through what
you are going to explore in this video
first you will understand what is basic
attention token following that the
working of that after that you will
understand how to use basic attention
token and then you will learn how you
can earn bad rewards and at the end you
will see what is basic attention token
used for so without any further Ado
let's get started with what is basic
attention token
the ethereum network serves as the
foundation for the decentralized open
source basic attention token digital
advertising ecosystem some of the topics
addressed by the project in relation to
Internet advertising include data
security data ownership and consumer
benefit its goal is to create an honest
transparent and Equitable system
advertisers will be able to Target users
directly and reward them with tokens for
the attention with the help of that in
contrast to traditional advertising
systems that use personal data to Target
ads bad users a blockchain based system
that allows users to opt into anonymous
ad targeting users can choose to view
relevant advertisements without having
their personal information shared with
advertisers but prioritizes your privacy
and gives you back control over your
data this raises the question of how Pat
is able to do this well the ethereum
blockchain serves as the basic attention
tokens Foundation as we know its
creators have collaborated with the
brave browser to implement the
Innovative advertising strategy Brave
has implemented the basic attention
metric or bam attention measuring system
it uses an anonymous Ledger system to
distribute money between readers content
readers and advertisers in fact it
brings them together for so many reasons
for example any content creator can
publish a post on their website now
advertisers offer a certain number of
basic attention tokens for ads based on
their content after that they will reach
an agreement based on the attention
score on the basis of user engagement it
basically means that ads are more
tailored to users and give the
advertisers the window of profit
ensuring that brave users see well
tailored ads while it also improves paid
privacy and security of the browser so
now that you have understood the
functioning of basic attention token let
me tell you how you can use a basic
attention token now because payments are
made in the form of tokens there are
numerous opportunities for seamless use
the first is to donate them to publisher
and other content creator this could
even include providing premium content
to donors these tokens can also be used
to purchase digital products such as
data service is on the brief platform
itself now how exactly to earn these bad
rewards now the first step is to
download the brave browser you can then
sign up for brave rewards by clicking on
the triangle next to the search bar
and then you can now start earning that
tokens simply by viewing advertisement
now advertisements appear as background
images push notification or cards in
your news feed which is the second step
they are not included in videos or
pop-ups making the experience seamless
and unobtrusive so now that you have
understood the basics let me tell you
the usage of bat
first is advertising The Advertiser in
this case provides the tokens that will
be distributed to those who view their
advertisements users who choose to
participate in bad rewards are also part
of this advertising ecosystem they are
compensated with tokens for each
advertisement they watch based on the
amount of time and attention they devote
to it second is tipping now that makes
it simple to Express gratitude to your
favorite content creators you can use
your tokens to tip internet users such
as twitch streamers YouTubers and
Twitter users this Fosters a passionate
community of users and creators allowing
for the creation of better content and
third is special access bat can also be
used to allow content creators to create
exclusive content for users who tip or
pay them thus free and paid content can
coexist in a unified ecosystem this also
enables creators to give back to their
communities by creating exclusive
content for those who actually support
them so well this was all about what has
basic attention token if you like this
video then do give it a thumbs up and
share it with your friends and do
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more such interesting content also if
you have any questions regarding this
topic then please feel free to ask away
in the comments section our team will
reach back to you as soon as possible
till then keep learning thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here